si on décelait faire une sorte de bilan
de ce mouvement ne lisons cuisiner en
france est ce qu'on peut en trouver des
traces concrètes agent logiciel ce jour
de soleil les gens du soleil truc
c'était ce pas gagné néopaganisme
technologie technocratique
c'est rigolo bon on en trouve plein de
traces valeur des informations
télévisées le tout ce qui a pu être pris
pour donner à l'image un sens de mounir
moderne
d'une certaine façon été repris fait bon
la rue décoration des bureaux paysagers
des grands ensembles de ses déficits et
qui traînait multifils l aménagement du
territoire
est ce que c'est ce que certains se sont
intégrés complètement
c'est une négation ou s'agit recteur de
banque ou bien sûr sa maman le par
exemple des gens qui ont été touchés par
par les idées des designers et en
national
lorsque les banques et regardez ils ont
les cheveux plan que les autres mais bon
ils ont été touchés est ce qu'ils
étaient et pigeons se dire moi je veux
dire c'est le mot hippie lui même
et quand on se reporte à l'origine du
mot ça voulait dire dans le vocabulaire
du jazz dans les années 40 voulait dire
petits blancs qui comprend rien au jazz
l'origine de mouiller et puis quand même
faut pas déconner donc je veux dire mon
bassine avec des mots c'est les médias
qui font ça l'épisode est pas homogène
et y en avait qui étaient des
techniciens fou il y en a maintenant
plein d'un du sony computer aux états
unis donc la frange la plus avancée du
computer cette tenue par les mac à
cheveux longs qui se laisseront pas
coupé et donc et en même temps il ya des
mecs qui se bat avec des brand bâtons
dans les pyrénées 50 brebis qu'on peut
aussi qualifier de hippies en rien à
voir les uns avec les autres
c'est comme si on parle des ouvriers on
est toujours les ouvriers comme s'il
était évidemment il y ait une conscience
collective
là il ya un certain ni un corps d'idées
collectif mais la destinée des individus
a changé parce que le propre
le seul mot d'ordre cast pour moi qui a
toujours été d'actualité qui sera
toujours dans ma vie et qui était un mot
d'ordre hippie s'était fait ton truc de
ouf c'est bon donc mais fait le quel
qu'il soit fait le jeune homme ne soit
pas dans la situation dans lequel
c'était aujourd'hui la place et beaucoup
de monde qui est une situation où on dit
on parle ce qu'on voudrait faire tout le
temps on ne fait jamais bon ça ce mot
d'ordre et reste r existe fort précis